i'm delighted to say that we are joined
now by the sri lankan prime minister
grinnell rickron singhi uh mr mr rickman
singing thanks so much for joining us i
guess
congratulations on on being appointed
prime minister i'm sure you would have
liked it to be in in very different
circumstances circumstances which we
were just discussing are pretty dire for
your country who is to blame for the
current situation
well i would say the last administration
is to blame
and
they have run down the economy
we've come to a point where we are
bankrupt which has never happened to sri
lanka before
we have no dollars we have no rupees
and if the current administration
is
to blame then have we seen enough
punishment for them
yet uh of course the president uh is
still
in power his brother the prime minister
may have stepped down but their family
has essentially run the country for two
decades should the president resign
well that's a controversy because the
people at goldface all the youths of the
view that president should resign
that so we also held
outside
and by some of the political parties
on the other hand the buy so say no the
view that the executive presidency
should be abolished they do not mention
anything
about the president resigning
so there are two different views i i
have suggested that once we pass the
21st amendment we should restore the
original 19th amendment strengthening
parliament strengthening the powers of
the prime minister then all party
leaders and the president should have a
discussion and come to some arrangement
on the future course
in the meantime clearly there are
massive protests across the country
uh often against uh the president
himself and and seeing
very firm responses a lot of arrests uh
tear gas at times and some firm handling
by police what is your view towards
those protesters can you understand
their anguish at the moment or is it
always wrong to take to the streets in
in the way that some are
no no i
i can understand the anguish of the
protesters
the young
and the old
the young who see their future being
taken away and the old which is
suffering the middle class who just see
their lifestyle collapsing
farmers
without fertilizer there are many many
demonstrations outside police stations
outside petra stations and other places
those are small ones and it shows the
anger the despair and the hopelessness
that the people feel the demonstration
that you have shown now
is by a militant youth group who
generally carries out at least five to
six demonstrations a year
and they
certainly
their aim is to ensure the water cannons
are used on them but that does not mean
that there are no protests in sri lanka
they are they are small protests run by
people at the moment when they can't
bear the burden any longer
we are not in a
we certainly are not in a very stable
position
i mentioned in in the introduction prime
minister that inflation is at 30 perhaps
due to rise to 40 percent and you
mentioned of course the blame that falls
on the past administration
do you think the effects of the war in
ukraine have been felt yet in sri lanka
or could things get worse in the short
term
well we are feeling the
rise
in the price of full we are feeling that
and we know it will go higher our main
concern also is that we have not had
fertilizer for cultivation and this
coming
season
the rice cultivation season
will not have the full production
therefore from about august onwards
there's a possibility of a food crisis
in sri lanka that's about the time
that the global food crisis will also
take place
and we have to see how we survive till
about march
and next year
and what is your message prime minister
in the short term to potential uh
international partners that could come
to your aid on a week when you've had to
miss interest payments due on on your
debt
it's a tricky position i guess to seek
seek help at that time
as well as missing those sorts of
payments
well we were in default anyway and we
didn't have the money to pay
we have to acknowledge that
i feel ashamed about it but nevertheless
this is
uh reality
i we've been engaging our partners and
they've responded well we've been
engaging with imf but as you know it
takes time
india has been the quickest
to respond we've had money
money from them which has enabled us to
carry on
but we think in the next few months
there will be
responses by the other donors
at the moment would you say it's safe
for tourists to come and visit sri lanka
well those who want to have an exciting
time could come here and maybe they
could even take part in the
demonstrations they could hold placards
which says for the president of sri
lanka to go home or you could hold a
placard asking the prime minister of
your country to go home all that is
option that's available
well i mean it's good to see you being
being like-hearted but but it was
actually a serious question i mean
tourism is an important part of
any emerging markets uh income
you're not
encouraging people to visit or are you i
mean i i it's a genuine question
it's not that we
we are not discouraging people
from visiting but we understand with the
shortage of foreign exchange and some of
the demonstration that is going on and
the shortage of essentials
that they may not visit sri lanka at
this time
um for my final question it's you
sounded very very honest about the
troubles and it's encouraging to hear
the frankness and of course we wish you
success in solving the problems but i
just wanted to to return to the question
of of the president and his family
because in an interview you gave to the
bbc
uh i think four days ago
you said there's no point looking at the
books because the books are cooked i i
guess my question is what did you mean
exactly by that and
are you suggesting outright corruption
by the president in which case surely
there should be much greater punishments
for him and his family
now many corporations statutory
corporations have not presented the
correct accounts similarly there are
questions about the
figures shown by the treasury we already
find that what was supposed to be
2.6
billion trillion revenue has come down
to 1.6 trillion
similarly
we have to look at the
books or the other entities within the
treasury whether different individuals
did it or one person coordinated it we
do not know
but it have been happening for over 10
years
for two years
i don't think it is basically
been an effort to show that the sri
lankan economy is normal when it was not
then many bills were non unpaid and the
government was not uh
informed of the the inability to pay
bills so these are really issues of
books being kept the accounts that's why
i used the term the books have been
cooked certainly it had been cooked and
it was to show that the economy was
normal when it fact it was not prime
minister thank you so much for joining
us uh this evening on on sky news uh and
uh best of luck